what's principals hard work works in  every country yes  reading books works in what countries  everything every country right wanting  to improve works where everything having  a proper diet works in what country all  country taking care of yourself and  staying clean works on what country in  every country learning how to deal with  people works in what countries anyway  that's what I Bank off that's what I've  been gone now let me give you the other  side you ready to the other side this  prostitution exhibit exists in every  country yes yes do crimes exist in every  country yes do arguments exist in every  country do divorces exist in every  country do bankruptcies exist in every  country yeah so principles and bad  habits are everywhere  you